welcome the general secretary and other
political Bureau standing committee
members
it might have been expected but the
confirmation was momentous nonetheless
president XI leading his new team into a
new era an era where he'll remain in
charge for as long as he sees fit
what the world watch today was an
assertion of pure power
according to precedent she served his 10
years and should now step down but he'll
stay for at least five more this is a
man with a vision unafraid of what
realizing it might mean
the journey ahead is long and arduous
but with determined steps we will reach
our destination we will not be daunted
by high winds choppy Waters or even
dangerous storms for the people will
always have our back and give us
confidence he's now the most powerful
leader here since Chairman Mao and those
flanking him confirmed it these men are
at the Apex of China's political system
a new top team stuffed with allies and
Loyalists no clear successor no hint of
challenge but Xi Jinping is a man with a
mission he is going to tighten control
even more to make sure there's the whole
party and the whole country will be
completely United in following his
instructions and moving China in a
direction that he has set and the
implications reach far beyond these
Shores from political relationships
redrawing the world order to policies
that have impacted a global economy his
China is one to be reckoned with what
we've seen this week is no doubt an
historic consolidation of xi's power but
also of his vision for this country it's
a China That's stronger and more
assertive but it's also a place where
Descent of any kind isn't tolerated any
deviation from this path now feels
increasingly unlikely
[Music]
on a sunny Sunday in the capital not
everyone was paying attention to
politics in she's China even passing
comment comes with risk but he has made
this country richer and more powerful
and that's what people tend to focus on
but there are occasional cracks a sense
that some still suffering
the president's going to be in power for
at least another five years maybe longer
what do you think of that yeah
when China moves the world now listens
its future for now feels fixed it's fate
largely in the hands of one man Helena
Smith Sky News in Beijing